[MUSIC PLAYING]
We are here at the red
carpet premiere of Spider-Man:
No Way Home.
I am your host, Meghan Camarena.
And I'm Josh Saleh.
And we're so excited to talk
to the talent and creators
of this incredible film
at the iconic Westwood
Village Theater in Los Angeles.
MEGHAN CAMARENA:
Brought to you by Marvel
Unlimited, your
all-access pass to over
29,000 Marvel digital comics.
JOSH SALEH: Check out
marvel.com/unlimited for more
information or click
on that QR code
that pops up on your screen.
MEGHAN CAMARENA: Now
let's talk to the cast
and crew of Spider-Man:
No Way Home, exclusively
in theaters December 17.
Hey Marvel fans, we are
here with David Dastmalchian.
We are on the carpet right
now for Marvel Spider-Man:
No Way Home right now.
How excited for you
for this carpet?
I'm so excited being back on a
Marvel red carpet at a premiere
for a Marvel film and it's
Spider-Man and all the exciting
things that are about
to happen in this
movie that I've just been
teased by with the trailer.
I'm like, I know we're all
about to get our minds blown,
but this is like historic
Marvel filmmaking right now.
Because there's all these
elements to this new movie
that we've never
gotten to see before.
Absolutely, is there anyone
you're super excited to see
on the carpet today?
I was really hoping I'd get
to run into Alfred Molina.
I don't know if he's around.
I mean, Tom and Zendaya and
all the incredible stars
of this movie, like I'm
big fans of everybody
that is a part of the movie.
So I'm just geeking
out over everybody.
That's awesome.
Now Spider-Man is beloved
by the entire world.
What makes him so relatable
to you and everybody else?
It's like when you were a
teenager and all of a sudden,
you're everything
starts changing
and the world seems like
it doesn't make any sense,
Peter Parker is the embodiment
of that for all of us.
His body starts changing, all
these things start happening
that he has no control over.
And all of a sudden, he
has this choice to make.
Like what am I going to
do with all this change?
Am I going to do something
to make the world better
or am I going to turn all that
anger and confusion and fear
into something dark?
And he continues to inspire
us because over the decades,
Peter Parker and
Spider-Man continue
to rise to the occasion
and be the hero
that we need them to be.
I absolutely love
that-- hope, positivity.
Enjoy the red carpet.
Thank you so much
for being here.
Thank you.
Thanks, everybody.
What's up Marvel fans
we're here with Chris McKenna
and Erik Sommers, the
writers of the film.
Y'all have so much
to juggle in this.
There are so many characters.
Where do you even begin?
We didn't know where to begin.
We honestly, we--
after the last movie,
there were a lot
of different things
that we couldn't
do in a good way.
I think those kind of
limitations are good.
But once the idea of the
multiverse opened up to us,
obviously there was an
infinite number of ways to go
and almost an embarrassment of
riches in terms of what we had
to choose from, but also
restrain ourselves because we
knew we had to tell one story.
Yeah, I would just
say that with the other,
with the preceding two
Spider-Man movies, we always
had to-- and with this one--
we had some housekeeping
to do dealing
with the larger MCU and other
things that had happened.
And we had limitations
always, a lot
of which were fun to deal with.
But in this one in
addition to that,
we then just had this door open
to the multiverse and just a
truly an infinite
number of possibilities.
And it was almost overwhelming.
And it took us a long time to
just talk and talk about it
and realize, like what is the
most fun we could have with it?
And hopefully we did.
And with the
multiverse, we have
super villains from previous
Spider-Man films in this.
What was it like to write
for those characters?
Daunting, it was
really daunting.
You know, we had already watched
those movies so many times.
But now we had to really
watch them again and really
try to live up to,
make sure we're
living up to the characters.
But, you know, I mean, Sam
Raimi is a hero of ours
and Marc Webb is an
incredible filmmaker.
We wanted to do justice to the
worlds that they had created,
but also make sure that they fit
into the world that, you know,
that we've been so
honored to be a part of.
So it was a juggling act,
you know, it really was.
It's funny, you know, the
previous Spider-Man movies are
movies that I would find
myself quoting with friends
or just in a room with
writers discussing
something for reference.
And this is the first
time we're suddenly
in my career I was writing
for those characters
that I just thought were like
some kind of amazing reference
or something I was a fan of.
And, yeah, it was
daunting, it was daunting.
But it was also
really, really fun.
What's up, Marvel fans?
I am here with JB Smoove.
What is up?
How are you?
Hi.
My wife, Shah.
MEGHAN CAMARENA: Your wife,
who's this lovely lady?
Shah XO right
here, yes, indeed.
You look so beautiful tonight.
I love this pink on
you like cotton candy.
Oh, thank, thank you.
And we love cotton candy.
Gosh, I like it here.
This is great.
You guys are great.
Can you stay here all night?
This is awesome.
We can, we can
for a little while.
Well, you both
look incredible.
I feel like that
has to be stated.
You guys look wonderful.
I have a question,
what has Mr Dell been
up to since we last saw him?
Mr. Dell has been--
his superpower is the
power of knowledge.
You know, unlike these amazing
powers that Spider-Man has,
this power lies in books.
His power lies in motivating
these young people to become
better versions of themselves.
And that's his power.
It's an amazing gift,
amazing gift of power.
And I'm a man of science.
Mr. Dell is truly
a man of science,
as you saw in the
previous movie.
He just wants to make sure these
young people get their exposure
to science that they need.
Science makes the
world go round.
As y'all would say.
I like that.
That's a superpower we all have.
Yeah.
What are you most excited
for with the film tonight?
I want to see my husband.
Like, of course, I love
Spidey, but this is my man.
Like I can't wait to see
him do his thing in it.
So that's my truth.
No, I love that.
That's so exciting.
So everyone knows Peter
Parker is Spider-Man.
How does Mr. Dell react to that?
How does he feel about it?
Mr. Dell was pretty upset.
When you have a student's
back for all this time
and you find out something like
this that they didn't tell you
and you felt you had a close
relationship with this student
and this is what happens,
you know, they pull
the wool over your eyes and you
find out something like this,
Mr. Dell was pretty upset.
He was not too happy about that.
MEGHAN CAMARENA: A
little heartbreaking.
He thought they
were like, like this.
But it turns out
they were like this.
It be like that sometimes.
Well, it was so lovely
talking with you guys.
Have an amazing rest of your
night and enjoy the movie.
It's going to be fabulous.
We cannot wait.
Woo.
Hi Marvel fans, I'm
here with Arian Moayed.
How's it going?
How are you feeling?
I am feeling
overwhelmed, excited.
I cannot wait to see
it on a big screen.
I'm like over the moon
about this whole thing.
How does it feel to
be a part of the MCU?
It's surreal.
I'm not going to lie to you.
It's completely surreal
to be a part of Marvel.
You know, I was
born in Iran and so
to have that be from
there to here is
a real surreal moment for me.
So I really, really,
you know, I'm just,
I'm just honored
and blessed, really.
Oh, that's so good to hear.
Well, I'm excited for you.
What are you looking forward
to most in the film tonight?
I am looking
forward to, selfishly,
I'm looking forward
to my interrogation
with Ned, spoiler.
OK, OK.
But most, like most of what
I'm really looking forward to
is watching Tom
Holland and watching
all these folks make
these amazing human beings
come to life.
I mean, that's where
I'm looking forward to.
I mean, this is big.
This film, everyone
knows who Peter Parker's
secret identity is Spider-Man.
How does your character
feel about that?
Obviously, he's
interrogating him.
So he comes in and really
interrogates the group
and really kind of tells
them, listen, you shouldn't
have done that, you know?
Anyway, I'm really just
excited to be here,
and a small part of this movie.
What's up Marvel fans?
I'm joined by Paula Newsome.
How's it going?
It's going great.
This is terribly exciting.
You know, we don't know too
much about your character.
What's it like joining the MCU?
You know what?
I'm going to tell
you that when Twitter
started kind of going agog,
they thought I was MJ's mama.
Not to say that I'm not,
you know what I'm saying?
But what's really fun
about this is joining this,
it's like coming into halftime
when the game is already going
and you jump in and it's
like, I got to keep up,
I got to keep up,
I got to keep up.
It's fabulous.
Well, I bet you did amazing.
Thank you.
So everyone knows that
Peter Parker is Spider-Man.
How does your character
feel about that?
You know, she's not
so enthused by him.
I'm not going to
give away too much.
MEGHAN CAMARENA:
And that's the tea.
That's true.
She doesn't much
like him that much.
Because she's not impressed.
I mean, what do you got?
What do you got?
Whoa.
OK.
I'm taking that.
I'm going to keep that.
I'm going to hold that while
I go into the theaters.
What are you excited
to see tonight?
I'm excited to see the
movie in its entirety.
Jon Watts, our
director, is amazing.
I got to work with
an amazing group
of actors, Fred Molina, Tom.
You know, we were there for a
month in the middle of Atlanta
just along with my stunt double.
I look forward to
seeing the whole thing.
You know, the whole
multiverse vibe, come on now.
I mean, you chose a great time
to show up, I'm just saying.
Well, I don't want to keep you.
You have the rest of
the red carpet to go.
And enjoy the film.
Congratulations again.
Thanks, love.
Hey Marvel fans.
I'm joined by Sarah Finn.
How are you doing?
Well, I'm great.
It's very exciting
to be here tonight.
How are you?
I'm speechless.
This is incredible.
What has it been like to
see these young adults
that you cast grow into the
characters that they are now?
Yeah, it's a little
emotional, isn't it,
to think about the
journey and when we first
cast Tom and
Zendaya and Jacob, I
think Jacob's screen test
was his first time he ever
set foot on a set in his life.
And now to see how
far they've come
and have the end of
the trilogy here,
I'm very excited
to see the movie.
I haven't seen it yet.
I'm very excited to see it
and to see how the fans react.
Well, you've done an
incredible job at casting.
Kudos to you.
What was it like
bringing back characters
like William and Alfred?
Am I allowed to
talk about that?
I don't think so, Meghan.
I mean, it was in the trailer.
Come on, Sarah.
I think you can.
Oh yeah.
It's bonkers.
This movie is as big as
anything we've ever done.
And it's really exciting to
see how they're all going
to interact on screen together.
Did you ever think
that would happen?
No, I didn't, I didn't.
When I first heard the
idea for the movie,
I thought, this is impossible.
But--
But here we are.
Here we are.
OK.
Was there a moment where
you're like, I don't
know if we can pull this off?
This is so big.
This is the biggest
Spider-Man film yet.
Yes, luckily on my
end, a lot of the cast
was already in existence
that I had cast
and from other wonderful
casting directors
who worked on this film
in much earlier versions.
So in terms of
pulling it off, I'm
going to toss that ball to the
incredible production people,
our producers, Amy,
Rachel, Kevin Feige, Jon
Watts, everyone who
worked so hard to pull
off a movie on this scale.
Hi Marvel fans.
I am here with Victoria
Alonso, executive producer.
How are you doing?
- I'm great.
I'm excited.
Now Zendaya is coming.
So that's the party right there.
We got a party
going on here too.
Yes, today is a good day.
Today is a good day.
We get to celebrate Spider-Man,
one of my favorite characters--
not the favorite,
but one of my--
Nice save.
They're all my favorites.
Tonight is a big night.
This is the biggest Spider-Man
film that we've seen to date.
And the effects are on
a whole other level.
Can you talk about
that just a little bit?
Just there's just so
much that went into this.
You know, the thing about
working on these things,
it just feels--
during the pandemic,
this took far more effort
because we were not together.
And I think that what I longed
for is to be together again.
But we got it done
thanks to the 6,000-plus
people across the world.
So I think every single
vendor, facility, human,
artist, and family
member that put
up with us working from home.
And hopefully you
can all go see it.
And shh, keep the secrets.
I thought you were
going to tell us a secret.
Shh, I'll say-- no,
are you kidding me?
I'm not saying anything.
OK, all right, all right.
Well, what are you most excited
about with this film tonight?
I'm excited to see how
people react to something that
has been with us for so long.
So I'm just ready, ready for
all of you to know what I know.
OK, well, I'm
ready for that, too.
How did you and your
team pull this off?
Well, you know, every
movie takes a lot of effort.
So it just, it was
effort, effort, effort.
And we have the best team.
You know, Amy, Kevin, we have
Jon Watts who is fantastic,
and we have a beautiful trio
and Zendaya and Tom and Jake.
And the friends are back.
They're back in town.
So they get to
tell another story.
That's beautiful.
Well, what does this
night mean to you?
I hope that this gift of
filmmaking that we put out
there to the world is
received with as much love
as we made it.
That made my heart
feel like mushy.
I love that.
I don't want to keep you.
Enjoy the rest of
your red carpet.
And I look forward
to seeing the film.
Thank you.
Thank you for your support.
And if I don't
see you anymore, I
think that's it for this year.
We have nine projects
that came this year.
Happy holidays.
We represented with
all of our hearts.
So we'll see you, after this,
we'll see you next year.
All right, see you.
Thank you.
Hey Marvel fans.
We're here with Amy Pascal.
This is an incredible movie.
What does it feel like to get
this off the ground running?
Look, it's fantastic.
People are out.
People are excited.
People love Spider-Man.
It's great.
So Spider-Man, talking
about the love of Spider-Man,
he's so relatable.
What makes Spider-Man
so beloved by all?
I think because
Spider-Man means
something different to
everyone at different
ages in their life.
You know, when you're a little
kid, it means one thing.
When you're a teenager,
something else.
And when you're grown
up, something else.
You know, it's a
boy who's always
struggling with being good.
And I think we all
understand that.
We were able to bring the
super villains from previous
Spider-Man into this film.
What was that process like that?
It was fantastic
because, of course,
I had worked with all of
them on the other films.
And it was really exciting
to bring them back.
Out of your entire
Spider-Man journey,
what are you most proud of?
Tonight, of course.
I love it.
Amy, thank you so much.
Enjoy the movie.
Thank you so much.
What's up Marvel fans?
We're here with Jon Watts,
the director, and family.
So Jon is an incredibly
incredible director.
We've seen two Spider-Man
movies already.
What makes him so amazing?
That's intense.
Well, he's our brother.
He's our baby brother,
yeah, he's the baby brother.
I wanted to bring my
family on the red carpet just
because, you know,
historically, Spider-Man is out
there helping regular people.
That's what he does.
And my family
literally does that.
My brother is a firefighter.
My sister is a nurse.
My other sister
here is a teacher.
And they're like
actually out there
on the front lines
legitimately helping
people over this past
terrible year and a half.
So I just wanted to sort of take
a little bit of the spotlight
off of me and shine on them and
all the people that have been
doing great things to
help people in this really
tough couple of years.
That's amazing.
That's incredible.
That's your answer.
So Jon just spoke about
how you inspire him.
How does he inspire you?
Oh my goodness.
I bring them to
red carpet events.
They get to meet Tom
Holland and Zendaya.
Now this is a huge, huge
film, where did you even begin?
Well, at the end
of the last movie,
we kind of gave ourselves
a really big ending where
we revealed Peter's identity.
So we started there.
Straight to the
point, I love it.
Now super villains
from previous Spider-Man
movies are in this film.
What was it like to
be a part of that?
Oh, it was great.
I mean, I'm a fan
of those movies.
So to have them there,
I was just being
a nerd like everyone else.
What's up Marvel fans?
We're here with Simu Liu.
What is going on?
We're here at the live carpet.
How does it feel?
It feels pretty great.
I'm not sure that
these people realize
that I'm not in this movie.
I think they-- you
know, I'm not going
to burst their bubble for them.
No spoilers, no spoilers.
No spoilers at all.
Anything is possible.
But I'm also not in this movie.
So who are you most
excited to see in this film?
I'm excited to see Spider-Man.
No spoilers.
Whichever Spider-Mans--
question mark?
I'm excited to-- no, no, I mean,
I've been reading the rumors
like everybody else.
I'm so fortunate to
get to be here to get
to watch this movie early.
And I'm just excited to
see where they take it.
I've been such a fan of
the Spider-Man movies
ever since Tobey Maguire.
I think it's just been a really
long ride and a full circle
moment for a lot of people.
So I'm jazzed.
I'm excited.
Let's talk about that.
Previous super villains
are in this movie.
What was your reaction
when you found out?
I was pretty--
OK, OK, well, first of all,
I was like oh my god, Doctor
Octopus is in the trailer.
And then I was like,
oh my god, like Jamie
Foxx is there as Electro.
And then it was like
oh my god, he's got
the Stark tech on his armor.
So I was like, what
does that mean?
I feel like everyone
was, you know,
pretty blown away
by all of that.
I think, you know, I
work for this company
so I know people at Marvel.
They're master marketers.
They're mysterious.
They work in mysterious ways.
They operate behind a veil
of secrecy and shadow.
And, you know, I'm just excited.
I'm so excited
that I finally get
to take a peek behind and see
what they've been cooking up.
You know, I feel
like I deserve to be
here because I used
to play Spider-Man
at kids' birthday parties.
I dressed up.
I inhabited the character.
You know, I was in the costume.
I really, I feel like
I was Spider-Man.
So in a way, I do feel
like this is my premiere.
Could I still hire you for
birthdays or is it too late?
You can, but the rate
is now $75,000 an hour.
Oh, no, Spider-Man.
It's gone up a
little bit, yes.
Thank you, Simu,
have a good one.
Take it easy.
Unlock the Marvel universe
of comics on your device in one
all-new, all-different app.
Gain instant access
to over 29,000
digital comics with
incredible new issues
added every single week.
Dive into exclusive
stories that will
forever change what you
know about the Mighty
Marvel universe.
Swing through Infinity
Comics, available only
on Marvel Unlimited.
There's so much more for you
in the app, True Believer.
Get started today.
What's up Marvel fans?
I am here with Benedict Wong.
How are you?
Hello, hello, ecstatic,
excited, a bit tired,
bleary eyed from
5:00 AM work call,
but as soon as I get in
there-- well, these are
waking me up as well actually.
[CHEERING] So, oh, it's just
fizzing with excitement,
you know?
It's an exciting
time to be here.
So you've been busy, Wong
has been very busy in Marvel
Studios, Shang-Chi and the
Legend of the Ten Rings, now
Spider-Man: No Way Home,
and, not to mention,
your upcoming film,
Doctor Strange
in the Multiverse of Madness.
There's a lot weighing
on Wong's shoulders.
How's he handling it?
I'm OK with a plum.
I got an email from
Kevin Feige saying
it's fast becoming the WCU.
So I'll take that.
So here we are.
The Wong Cinematic
Universe, I like it.
I like it, definitely.
Well, what is it like
to get a chance to dive
into the Marvel multiverse with
all the weird creative worlds
that it entails?
Well, we'll certainly have
to do a lot of versions.
And it's also kind of filming
as well during this sort of time
as well where
we're kind of like,
you know, if something happens,
you know, then we hit plan B,
we hit plan C. So we're kind
of living in a sort of quantum
filming schedule, you know?
So that's how it's been.
That must be
crazy as an actor.
Yeah, I mean I call
it like the madness
of the multi-schedule.
That's it, really.
You know, that's a strange that.
Well, before you leave,
what's something that you can
tell us that the fans
can look forward to,
maybe a little tease?
Well, you know,
there'll be a shift,
I think, definitely in
this which will hopefully,
you know, we'll see different
responsibilities I think,
you know?
Marvel fans I'm here
with Marisa Tomei.
How's it going?
Going good, getting
very excited for everyone
to see this movie.
It's the big opening.
The energy is amazing.
I'm so excited.
Yeah, it's very,
it's really thrilling.
What has May been up to
since we last left off?
Well, her and Peter Parker
have gone through a lot
together.
They're growing up.
They've been through
several cycles
of on and off relationships
with other people.
I don't know.
They're hanging out.
I mean, that's a lot.
So everyone knows that
Peter Parker is Spider-Man.
How is May handling that?
I think that, well,
May was shocked at first.
And then, you know,
then she found out.
And they became a team.
They just really
worked together.
And she's in on it with him.
And she also tries
to protect the part
of him that's still a boy
and lets him do his thing.
I love that.
So and you just spilled
the tea, all right?
May has a kind of a different
understanding when it comes
to her relationship with Happy.
Is there a relationship there?
What's going on?
I don't think--
I mean, there's a relationship,
there's a friendship.
And they've also,
they're like compadres.
They've been through
so much together.
They've been lovers.
They've been friends.
They've been on.
They've been off.
I don't know why you think
I have a different-- why?
Do you have a different
understanding?
I mean, the last
movie, it was kind
of like a little back and--
Oh, yeah, yes yes, yes, true.
What was it like to work with
this incredible cast again?
Oh, it's just so
great to see them.
They're always doing
something new and different
and they just--
they're so beautiful.
They're beautiful to look at.
They're beautiful inside.
And it's always fun to come
back and be with them again.
Well, I'm excited to see
you on the big screen tonight.
I won't keep you
from the red carpet.
Thank you for
spending time with us.
Thanks, thanks to you.
Marvel fans, I am
joined by Xochitl Gomez.
How's it going?
I'm doing great.
I'm nervous.
I'm excited.
What are you looking
forward to seeing
most in this film tonight?
Well, number one, my homies,
Benedict Cumberbatch and Benny
Wong, got to support the crew.
I'm really excited to see
just this movie in general.
Have you been a Spider-Man
fan for a long time?
Oh yeah, I'm like, who hasn't
been since like five years old,
I mean, are you kidding me?
That makes sense.
You're right.
So there's quite a bit of
crossover between the cast
and the cast in your upcoming
film, Marvel Studios' Doctor
Strange in the
Multiverse of Madness,
what is it like
working with Benedict
Cumberbatch and Benedict Wong?
Oh, I mean, it's
pretty insane.
I'm a pretty lucky person.
It's pretty crazy.
I just love watching them get in
their character and their zone.
And it's just been wonderful
like teaching experience,
honestly.
It's just crazy to be like, oh
my gosh, I know these people.
It's kind of funny.
I bet.
Who are you excited to see most
on this red carpet tonight?
Zendaya.
Girl, yes.
I'm excited.
I'm like, I'm like,
is she here now?
I'm waiting for the screams.
I know.
[CHEERING]
I hear some screams.
Could be her.
So I heard you skateboard.
Is that true?
Yes, I do a little
bit of skateboarding.
But ever since I started
getting some roles,
I was like, I can't
really injure myself here.
So I just, I just
grazed a little bit.
MEGHAN CAMARENA:
No crazy tricks.
No, no, no, no.
I might be able to have
like some fake blood
and stuff for work, but not
nothing in real life, nah.
That's a cool skill to have.
And you just celebrated
your quinceñera?
Yes, I did.
It was during COVID and stuff.
So I couldn't really have some
like huge thing, which, I mean,
I really wish I could have.
But I just went around the
park and around just LA
and just took some photos.
What's up Marvel fans?
We're here with Jacob
Batalon who plays Ned Leeds.
This is a huge film.
Where do we start
with Ned in this one?
Oh my goodness.
Ned is reeling.
You know, his best
friend's identity has just
been revealed to the world.
So he was just like,
what does he do next?
What are we up to now?
Like we're planning what to do.
It's crazy.
Does Ned to get on
the action on this one?
Oh my goodness, like
you wouldn't believe.
Ned and MJ are killing it.
Yes, so what was
it like working
with Benedict Cumberbatch?
I mean, unbelievable.
He's like so
professional, but also
such a funny,
amazing human being.
And everyone on the
cast has been amazing.
Every legend that's been
on has been just amazing.
So we know Ned's arc
throughout these films.
But what has been your
journey through this?
I feel like, I mean,
I've accomplished
everything that I've wanted
to accomplish with Ned.
I feel like he's definitely
become the guy in the chair
to like in the action.
So I think in that way,
he's had a great time.
So, yeah.
If you can have any
Spider-Man gadget in real life,
what would you choose?
Probably the webbed
wings so I can fly.
That's awesome.
Jacob, thank you so much.
Enjoy the movie.
Thank you.
What's up Marvel fans?
We're here with JK Simmons
who plays J. Jonah Jameson.
What was it like to come back
for this Spider-Man film?
Always a pleasure,
whatever incarnation--
I hope they keep
reincarnating JJJ.
Now what's the difference
between this J. Jonah Jameson
and the one you
played previously?
Only the hair really.
So this film is so massive.
What was it like working with
this incredible ensemble?
Well, I'll tell
you, I was in and out.
I still haven't met 2/3
of the cast of this movie.
I'm hoping I get that
opportunity tonight.
So who are you
excited to see tonight?
That kid who plays Spider-Man,
whatever his name is--
JOSH SALEH: What?
--and, you know,
the 75 bad guys,
some of whom are, you
know, old leftovers
like myself and some new ones.
Throughout your
Spider-Man journey,
do you have a favorite moment?
Can't pick one, not
going to even try.
What's up, Marvel fans?
We're here with Jon Favreau,
who plays Happy Hogan.
Now you started
the MCU directing
Marvel Studios' Iron Man.
What is it like to continue
that legacy of Iron Man
as Happy Hogan?
Well, I love being a
part of this as an actor
because I get to continue
to work with the people
that I work with on
the Iron Man films.
Also even before I
started directing,
I remember visiting the
set of Spider-Man 3.
That was my first experience.
So it's nice that it's
all coming together.
And I'm just happy that I've
been able to be a part of it
in one way or another
for decades now.
That's awesome.
Now that the entire world
knows who Spider-Man
is, how does that affect Happy?
Well, you know, Happy has
always been in on the secret
with Tony Stark,
with Peter Parker.
So Happy was always good at
being a professional wingman
to help out and
help them navigate
their way through
all the challenges
of being a superhero.
I think he offers a
lot of moral support.
I don't think he's too
good for protection,
even though he's supposed
to be head of security.
But I think he's a good friend.
And I think for Peter
Parker, he was a good,
I think he took it
upon himself to look
after him after Tony was gone.
So I really liked
playing that part.
And I really like
Tom Holland a lot.
And I loved popping onto
the set and working with Jon
Watts and everybody there.
It's a great group
of young actors.
And as an actor, I love it.
And I think it comes
through in the character.
That's awesome.
Now do you have a favorite
MCU moment in Spider-Man
through your journey?
Oh, in Spider-Man, I like
when we're in the bathroom,
I think we were in
the bathroom together
where I'm trying to
be like Nick Fury
popping into his high school.
And I confronted him.
And someone flushes the toilet.
So my really cool like Nick Fury
moment is completely undermined
by a toilet flushing.
Yeah, I like that one a lot.
Awesome, Jon,
thank you so much.
Enjoy the movie.
Thank you.
Have a good one.
What's up Marvel fans?
We're here with Willem Dafoe
who plays Green Goblin.
All right, what was your
reaction when you were
told the premise of this film?
Sounded good, good
enough to sign on,
you know, to revisit
this character.
Now what was it like
revisiting that character?
How was that?
It was great.
I mean, it's-- yeah,
it's a continuation.
And this is probably
the most ambitious
filming of the series so far.
So it was great to be a part
of it, see some old friends,
see some new friends, you know?
That's incredible.
What was it like working
with Director Jon
Watts and the awesome ensemble.
He was great.
I mean, you know,
a lot of the people
had worked together before.
So they really
had good chemistry
already and a lot of trust.
And, yeah, it was fun to work.
You know, very loose, but
also, you know, we were
making our days and having fun.
Do you have a favorite
Spider-Man moment in the MCU?
Oh, god, that's a tough one.
Yeah, too hard
again, there's so many.
You know, I enjoy
doing the action stuff.
Marvel fans, I am here with
Jamie Foxx, who plays Electro.
What is it like returning
to this character
after all this time?
It's been amazing, man,
like to be able to reboot
the character and new
look, new vibe, and my kids
here with me
representing Electro.
They got the shoes
to represent Electro.
They got the shoes.
So we've just been--
you know, just
been happy to be on
this ride and can't wait
for the world to see the movie.
What's different
about Electro this time?
Well, the way he
looks, right off the bat,
it's a different look.
He's simplified, potent,
kind of got a flyness to him.
And so everybody
online has been really
like reacting well to it.
So just can't wait for
people to check it out.
I heard you brought
your own flavor to it.
Yeah, yeah, you know, you
got to bring your flavor to it.
So, you know, the fact that
they were allowing, you know,
accommodating with that makes
the whole movie feel better.
Yeah.
Well, I'm excited to see it.
What's the best part about
playing a super villain?
Oh, it's always
good to be a bad guy.
It's good being bad,
you know what I mean?
So it's like you're
doing Electro,
there's so many layers when
you're a super villain,
you know what I mean?
So I can't wait for
you to check that out.
What's up Marvel fans?
We're here with Kevin Feige.
This is a huge
undertaking of a film.
Where did you start?
We started at
the ending of Far
From Home where we
knew that we had
put Peter Parker in a very
hard circumstance where
his identity was revealed.
And from there, we
decide what happens next.
And how do we make
things harder for him?
He's been to space.
He's become Spider-Man.
He's lost his mentor.
And now his identity
is revealed.
And all he wants to do
is graduate high school
and go to college.
And we started there.
And the good old
Parker luck kicked in.
You brought supervillains in
from previous spider-man movies
into this.
What was that process like?
It was very emotional.
It always starts
with the place of,
what do we think would be fun?
What do we think would be cool?
I've been making movies
for 20 years now at Marvel.
And they started at this very
theater, as a matter of fact,
with the premiere of Sam
Raimi's Spider-Man 1.
And we were sitting
around a room
and saying, if I saw Willem
Dafoe, who you just talked to,
as Green Goblin again
and Alfred Molina,
who's not able to be
here tonight, as Doc Ock,
I would lose my mind.
Just that starting
point and a lot of luck
came together that
they were interested,
we were able to bring them back.
Oh that's incredible.
I can't wait to see
this incredible film.
What are you most
proud of throughout
the Spider-Man films?
Well I'm proud of
the collaboration we've
had with Jon Watts
on three movies
with Tom Holland on
three of his own movies,
plus the Avengers movies.
The entire relationship between
Sony and Marvel and Disney
is really unprecedented
in Hollywood history.
And it's all because
everybody loves Spider-Man.
And that is amazing.
I hope it shows in all
the movies as well.
Well, you said that
everyone loves Spider-Man.
What makes him so
lovable and relatable.
I think that was
the genius of what
Steve Ditko and Stan Lee
did all those years ago
was they made him us.
They made him
flawed and related.
And, again, here he is in
this giant anticipated movie
that may or may not
have consequences
for the multiverse.
But Peter Parker just
wants to go to college.
Peter Parker just wants
to graduate high school.
That's it.
And you want to root
for that person.
Kevin, thank you so much.
Enjoy the movie.
Thank you so much.
Have a good night.
Thank you.
Marvel fans, I am here
with Zendaya, MJ herself.
How are you?
- I'm good.
I'm doing pretty great.
So I have a couple of questions.
This is the biggest
Spider-Man film yet
and there's a lot of stunts.
How did it feel to be a web
slinging and flying high?
Oh, man, it was so much fun.
I loved being able
to do that stuff,
especially because we
feel incredibly safe.
We have an amazing
stunt coordinator.
And you just get to have fun.
I'm not afraid of
heights in that way.
So I feel really good about it.
Well, I can't wait to see.
How has MJ changed
since we last seen her?
I think she's just
opening up more.
I think now that she has Peter
in her life and someone--
and Ned, obviously, people who
feel that love her for who she
is, I think she's
able to slightly just
open up a little bit
more and maybe even
be a little bit more positive.
Because usually she's like
the nihilistic friend, right?
She's the one that's
always looking
at things glass half empty.
So it's nice to see
that side of her.
Hello Marvel fans.
We're here with
Benedict Cumberbatch
who plays Doctor Strange.
You have had quite the
busy life, my friend.
Yep.
What is it like to dive
into the Marvel multiverse?
Marvel is a fun place to be
right now as Doctor Strange.
That's all I will say.
And, yeah, you know,
he brings something
very interesting to this film.
But most of all, having worked
with Tom-- not just on this,
but on a couple of other
projects-- it's just,
it's just wonderful to be by his
side again and doing what we do
and establishing and maturing
and growing that relationship.
It's fantastic.
What is it like
bringing Dr. Strange
into the world of Spider-Man?
A lot of fun, a lot of fun.
You know, I get to play the
grown-up surrounded by kids.
I could say that.
They're half my age.
They are kids.
I'm blown away by
their professionalism,
by the atmosphere
they create on set,
by the fun that is
to be on that set.
Jon Watts is a
phenomenal director.
He's such a joy to work with.
He's great on the granular.
He gives you context to
understand where your place is
in the story and the
development of it,
even when all the story
hasn't been finished,
which is often the way with
these films at the time
of production starting.
And it is just fun
from start to finish.
What goes through
Dr. Strange's mind.
After saving worlds
and universes,
a young Peter Parker
comes up saying, hey,
can you craft a spell
to have people forget?
I think the first thing that
goes through his mind, as you
see in the film, is like, yeah,
sure, I want to help you out,
kid.
You did great back there.
And you're one of them
and us and, you know,
we're doing-- we're all
on the same team here.
So, sure, I'll
help a friend out.
It doesn't really take
into account that he's
still a kid at high school.
And in trying to
people please or going,
yeah, OK, let's do one
for the team, yeah,
some crazy stuff is unleashed.
And that's where
the relationship
starts to evolve and
mature and that's
what I'm really excited about.
I mean, there's
some crazy reveals
and fun spills and
thrills in this.
But also, for me as an actor,
the thing that matters most
is that emotional
connection to a character
and the people who
surround him and the world
that surrounds him.
So with Tom and I, that's a
really beautiful relationship
that's kicking off.
What's up Marvel fans?
We are here with Tom Holland
who plays Peter Parker.
This is one of the biggest
Spider-Man films ever made.
What was your reaction
when you read the premise?
Oh, man, I was blown away.
I was also so skeptical.
At the time, I was
like, there's no way
that they could pull this off.
There's no way that
they'll be able to bring
these villains back into
this universe and make sense.
But they did.
And they've done it in
a wonderful fashion.
The movie is incredibly
heartfelt. It's funny.
It's emotional.
It's exciting.
And, you know, Jon
Watts has really
knocked it out of the park.
So to be here tonight
celebrating this movie,
I honestly cannot even begin
to explain to you how happy
I am and how excited I am.
If you had told me 10 years
ago that you'll be playing
Spider-Man in a movie like
this, I would have been like,
you're a liar.
Well, in a movie
like this, exactly.
Look at all these people.
They love you.
Movie like this, you're
playing opposite super villains
from previous Spider-Man movies.
What is that like?
It's incredible.
I mean, I've been a huge fan of
these movies since I was a kid.
I remember seeing
Tobey's movies.
Andrew's movies.
So to get the chance to share
the screen with their villains
has been one of the most
rewarding aspects of my career.
And I'm so lucky
to be here tonight.
I can't wait to share
the night with them.
And I'm seeing Tom Rothman over
there, my boss, who I love.
He's been so kind to me.
I want to go and
give him a big hug.
And, honestly, I
am beyond excited.
Peter goes through so much,
the death of Tony Stark,
Mysterio letting him know
that his entire identity, what
is that like for Peter
Parker in this film?
It's tough.
I mean, everyone's been
asking me in the press,
can you relate to it
because you're famous?
But I'm famous for making
movies and he's famous for being
a mass murderer.
So it's slightly different.
But it's been a very
exciting challenge, something
I've really enjoyed
taking on, bringing
to life in the character.
It definitely totally
shifts the movie.
It makes the movie feel very
different to the previous two,
which is great.
I love change.
And I love this movie.
And I love everyone here.
And it's awesome.
Tom, you've got a busy night.
Enjoy the premiere.
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
- Thank you so much.
- Have a good one.
Oh, that was amazing.
It was incredible-- so many
talented actors, the cast,
the crew, I'm speechless.
As am I. Let us know what
your favorite interview
was in the comments below.
MEGHAN CAMARENA: And
be sure to check out
Marvel Unlimited, your
all-access pass, over 29,000
Marvel digital comics.
JOSH SALEH: And check out
marvel.com/unlimited for more
information or click
on that QR code
when it pops up on the screen.
MEGHAN CAMARENA: And be sure
to check out Spider-Man:
No Way Home exclusively
in theaters December 17.
This is Marvel.
Your universe.